Conheça Maria. Ela é uma mãe dedicada,
esposa amorosa e profissional exemplar.
Todos os meses Maria enfrentava o
inimigo silencioso que a debilitava, que
eram as cólicas menstruais intensas. A
dor era tão forte que em alguns dias ela
não conseguia nem sair da cama. Certa
vez, já no aeroporto, pressa a embarcar
para uma importante viagem de trabalho,
as córicas foram tão intensas, tão
insuportáveis, que ela teve que cancelar
esse voo. E esse incidente quase lhe
custou emprego. Ela pensou que era algo
que ela tinha que conviver para sempre.
Até que um dia, que jamais esquecerá,
ela descobriu uma esperança que mudaria
a sua vida. As cólicas menstruais afetam
milhões de mulheres ao redor do mundo. E
não é apenas uma dor física, é um peso
emocional que impacta o trabalho, a
família e a qualidade de vida. Sentir-se
incapaz de realizar tarefas simples,
perder momentos preciosos com os filhos.
Tudo isso por causa de uma dor que
parece invencível, mas por que que
tantas mulheres sofrem em silêncio? Em
sua busca por alívio, a Maria encontrou
o pquenol, que é um suplemento natural
que prometia não apenas reduzir as
cólicas, mas também melhorar a sua saúde
menstrual como um todo. Era como
encontrar um raio de sol em um dia
nublado. Com esperança renovada, ela
então decidiu experimentar. Afinal, sua
felicidade e bem-estar dependiam disso.
Mas o que que torna o pequeninol tão
especial? Ele é extraído da casca do
pinheiro marítimo francês. Ele possui
propriedades anti-inflamatórias
potentes. As córicas menstruais são
causadas por contrações uterinas
intensas, que são mediados por
substâncias inflamatórias. E o
piquinogenol ele atua reduzindo essa
inflamação, aliviando a dor e
equilibrando os processos naturais do
corpo. Então imagine uma tempestade se
acalmando, dando lugar ao mar sereno.
Esse é o efeito do picnogenol.
Em um estudo, ele se demonstrou reduzir
significativamente a dor abdominal em
mulheres com cólicas menstruais. O
alívio foi ainda maior no segundo mês de
uso em comparação ao primeiro. Outro
estudo feito com todo o cuidado
científico reforçou essas descobertas. A
suplementação com piquinogenol não só
diminuiu a intensidade da dor, mas
também reduziu a necessidade de remédios
para aliviar. E o mais surpreendente, os
benefícios continuaram mesmo depois que
as mulheres pararam de tomar o
suplemento. E se você gosta de conteúdo
mais aprofundado ou se você é da área de
saúde, assista a aula completa sobre
pequenogenol no meu outro canal. Eu vou
deixar aqui o link na descrição e no
primeiro comentário.
Com o passar dos ciclos, a Maria começou
a perceber e a notar mudanças
significativas. As dores passaram a
diminuir. Os dias antes tem agora eram
vividos com leveza. Ela voltou a
participar ativamente da vida familiar,
a sorrir, a sentir-se plena. Não era
apenas a ausência de dor, mas a
reconquista de sua liberdade. O Pdogenal
não só aliviou as cólicas, mas também
devolveu a ela momentos que pensou ter
perdido para sempre. Então, se a
história de Maria tocou seu coração, não
ignore esse momento, informe-se sobre o
pequeninol, converse com profissionais
de saúde e assista a minha aula completa
no outro canal. Este pode ser o primeiro
passo para uma vida sem dores e cheia de
possibilidades. E não perca os próximos
vídeos dessa série. Eles podem ser a
chave para transformar sua vida e de
seus entes queridos e juntos podemos
construir um futuro melhor. Um grande
abraço. Um beijo no seu coração. Você é
fera. Ja.